pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient
il était adopté
l'amendement sans madame la rapporteur
de la commission des lois oui merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues cette amendement
sans ils arrêtent écrire pour la
deuxième fois l'article 4 qui est
relatif à la lutte contre le dopage et
l'introduction des tests génétiques en
commission des lois nous avions souhaité
comme je vous le disais lors de la
discussion générale rendre pérenne une
partie des tests génétiques pour mettre
en conformité le droit français avec le
code mondial antidopage notamment sur
les deux premières finalités les
substitutions d'échantillons et la
vérification qu'il n'y a pas de de sang
homologues enfin qu'il y a de ce
homologues pardon pour les transfusions
et les échantillons prélevés sur les
athlètes et puis maintenir une
expérimentation pour les deux dernières
finalités c'était ce qui était prévu
initialement on a continué nos
discussions après le passage en
commission des lois avec l'Agence
française de lutte contre le dopage avec
le gouvernement avec l'instance de
contrôle internationalité a et
finalement nous nous sommes rendus
compte que c'était pas très opérant et
donc nous vous proposons dans cet
amendement 100 de réécrire pour
pérenniser l'ensemble des tests
génétiques dans le cadre de la lutte
antidopage et donc pour doter la France
des mêmes outils que les autres pays et
faire en sorte que nos sportifs français
soient soumis sur le territoire français
à ces mêmes tests génétiques dans un
souci d'équité et dans un souci de
préservation de leur santé
si sur cet amendement il y a sous
amendement 104 madame Marie B
merci madame la Présidente avec cet
amendement la commission des lois si
vous me permettez l'expression change un
peu de pied au dernier moment
et ça explique bien les ambiguïtés du
texte ainsi que le montre l'évolution de
la rédaction de cet article 4 et qui a
expliqué un petit peu la rapporteur le
projet de loi avait prévu initialement
une expérimentation générale en matière
de test génétique la commission des lois
a opéré un premier distinguo entre les
tests visant à réaliser une comparaison
d'empreintes génétique quelle pérennise
et se permettant d'analyser un ou
plusieurs une ou plusieurs
caractéristiques génétiques c'était déjà
une première entaille à
l'expérimentation par rapport au texte
qui avait été déposé le projet de loi il
s'agissant des échantillons prélevés en
vue de l'examen des caractéristiques
génétiques la commission des lois avait
tout de même retenu la voie prudente de
l'expérimentation
et tout en introduisant modifications
importantes qui est en des
considérablement le périmètre et la
durée d'application de l'article 4
dans la dernière rédaction
l'institutionnalisation des dispositifs
présentés comme temporaire pour les
banaliser les inscrire dans le droit
commun finalement avec juste une clause
de revoyure nous pose problème ça nous
semble pas acceptable il nous semble que
ça doit être strictement limité dans les
finalités c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous proposons de maintenir le caractère
expérimental des tests de limiter cette
expérimentation à la période olympique
et paralympique et d'attendre la fin de
l'expérimentation et le rapport
d'évaluation pour en tirer les
conclusions qui s'imposent merci quelle
est la ville de la Commission sur ce
sous amendement
présidente mes chers collègues c'est un
avis défavorable puisque évidemment ce
sous amendement revient sur l'amendement
précédent que je vous ai présenté juste
pour préciser que certes il y a
pérennisation mais dans ces cas-là les
tests sont soumis à de nombreuses
garanties il ne peut pas y avoir
d'identification ils sont anonymes les
échantillons sont détruits
automatiquement s'il n'y a pas de
suspicion relevées etc et il y a une
information du du sportif donc c'est
pour ça que nous émettons un avis
défavorable quelle est la vie du
gouvernement sur l'amendement
sur l'amendement sans de Madame canaille
nous sommes favorables dans la mesure où
cette évolution du texte nous permettra
de nous mettre durablement en conformité
avec les exigences du droit
international également parce qu'il
permet de ne pas scinder en deux régimes
différents les quatre cas d'usage
limitativement énumérés par cohérence
nous sommes défavorables ou sous
amendement 104 en précisant bien que il
y aura un rapport d'évaluation qui sera
rendu le 31 décembre
2024 sur l'ensemble de cet article
je vais donc mettre un signal
basification de votre je vais dans mes
trouver le sous amendement qui a reçu un
double avis défavorable qui est pour
qui est pour le sous amendement
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté qui est l'amendement
sang qui a reçu un favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté
l'amendement l'amendement suivant tombe
l'article est donc ainsi modifié il n'y
a pas de soumette au vote et nous
passons 42 qui le défend madame Robert
monsieur Lauzac monsieur Lauzac
dans les présidents dans le cadre de la
préparation des jobs de 2024 la FLD
l'Agence française du lutte contre le
dopage mène en lien avec d'autres
administrations une politique active de
collecte des renseignements et de
transmission des informations reçues en
vue d'orienter les investigations
antidopage en amont puis lors des jeux
dans sa qualité d'organisation nationale
antidopage la FFD est habilité à mettre
en œuvre ses prérogatives pour établir
et sanctionner les violences non
analytiques des règles antidopage dans
cette perspective il y a l'ordonnance
d'avril 2021 qui a qualifié le cadre
légal d'échange d'informations
le permettant entre les services de
l'AFLD et tout un ensemble de services
qui relève du ministère de l'économie et
des finances l'expérience a cependant
démontré qu'il manque à cette liste tout
simplement track fin avec laquelle la
FFD apporte engagé une coopération
fructueuse alors il y a un article qui
permet d'échanger ces informations
en direction de track femme et la
réciproque n'a pas été prévue ce qui
nuit à l'efficacité des enquêtes
antidopage en cours et à venir dans la
perspective des échanges de 2024 c'est
pourquoi donc cet amendement autorise
les échanges d'information pour leur
mission respective entre la F et track
fin c'est une situation un peu analogue
on est rencontré avec la plateforme de
lutte contre la manipulation des
compétitions sportives on avait mis en
place la plateforme et puis on s'aperçu
un certain moment qui avait pas des gens
d'information possible en raison des
statuts des agents concernés
quelle est la ville de la Commission
madame la Présidente ministre un avis
favorable parce que nous pensons que
cela comble un trou dans l'organisation
et que ça permettra d'améliorer
largement la lutte contre le dopage
avis également favorable dans la mesure
où cette amélioration du partage
d'informations va renforcer notre
efficacité dans la lutte contre le
dopage merci mais on voit cet amendement
qui a reçu un double avis favorable qui